I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate Office Lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. Hi everybody. Hi there.
我是珍娜·费舍，我是安吉拉·金赛。我们曾一起出演《办公室》，我们是最好的朋友。现在，我们正为你们带来终极的《办公室》爱好者播客。每周，我们将通过独家采访、幕后细节和许多闺蜜故事，深入探索《办公室》的世界。我们是《办公室女士》6.0版。大家好。你们好。
You guys, we have a super talented, hilarious woman on the podcast today. Mm-hmm. We're really excited because we're big fans. It's Jenny Slate. Jenny Slate. Ah! She's a brilliant comedian, actor, writer, New York Times bestselling author, and now a podcaster, too, with her show. I need you guys.
各位，今天我们播客请到了一位非常有才华、非常风趣的女士。嗯哼。我们真的很兴奋，因为我们是她的超级粉丝。她是珍妮·斯蕾特。珍妮·斯蕾特。啊！她是一位才华横溢的喜剧演员、演员、作家、《纽约时报》畅销书作者，现在也是一位播客主持人，她有自己的节目。我需要你们。
And you might know her from her work in film and TV. I loved her as Mona Lisa in Parks and Rec. So much. So good. She also co-created Marcel the Shell with shoes, which I loved. There was all of these short films and a book series, and she got nominated for an Academy Award for the movie. for the movie version. Okay, so that's how I became a fan of hers,
你们可能通过她的电影和电视作品认识她。我非常喜欢她在《公园与游憩》中饰演的莫娜·丽莎。太棒了。太好了。她还联合创作了《穿着鞋子的贝壳马塞尔》，我非常喜欢。那是一系列短片和书籍，她还凭借电影版获得了奥斯卡提名。电影版。好吧，这就是我成为她粉丝的原因，
so I was trying not to geek out when I was talking to her. I know. I mean, I was the same. I remember discovering Jenny from watching the movie Obvious Child that she starred in with one of our The Office alumni, Jake Lacey. And in our interview, she talks about that film being a really pivotal moment in her career. But everyone, she is also an incredible voice actress. She has voiced characters in movies like The Lorax, Zootopia, Dispicable Me, The Secret Life of Pets, the Lego Batman movie, and Bob's Burgers.
所以我跟她聊天时尽量不让自己表现得太狂热。我知道。我的意思是，我也一样。我记得我是通过观看她与我们《办公室》校友杰克·莱西共同主演的电影《显然怀了孕》而认识珍妮的。在我们的采访中，她谈到那部电影是她职业生涯中一个非常关键的时刻。但各位，她还是一位出色的配音演员。她曾为《老雷斯的故事》、《疯狂动物城》、《神偷奶爸》、《爱宠大机密》、《乐高蝙蝠侠大电影》和《开心汉堡店》等电影中的角色配音。
Yeah. And now she has a new animated movie in theaters right now from DreamWorks animation called Forgotten Island. I am so excited about this movie. We're going to talk about it. But if that isn't enough, Jenny Slate is also an author, and we have a really great conversation with her about her new book, Life Form. and also a book called Notes to New Mothers. We end up getting in a really thoughtful conversation about motherhood. But hey, let's get to it.
是的。现在她有一部梦工厂动画制作的新动画电影正在影院上映，名叫《被遗忘的岛屿》。我对这部电影感到非常兴奋。我们将讨论它。但如果这还不够，珍妮·斯蕾特还是一位作家，我们与她就她的新书《生命形式》以及一本名为《给新妈妈的笔记》的书进行了非常棒的对话。我们最终进行了一场关于母性的深刻对话。但是，嘿，让我们开始吧。
Yeah, this is our conversation with Jenny Slate. Jenny, hi. Hello, Lady. Welcome to the podcast. Thank you. How many people come on this show and are like freaking out that they get to talk to you in the way that I am? Oh, that's very nice. I don't ever feel that because we just think we're just, you know, two kind of dorky gals that like to hang out.
是的，这是我们与珍妮·斯蕾特的对话。珍妮，你好。你好，女士们。欢迎来到播客。谢谢。有多少人来到这个节目时，像我一样因为能和你交谈而感到抓狂？哦，那太好了。我从来没有这种感觉，因为我们只是认为我们只是，你知道，两个喜欢聚在一起的傻姑娘。
So thank you for saying that. We're so thrilled to meet you. We're such big fans. I really am a big fan of yours. This is, I've always hoped that one of these many sort of like industry events that I would maybe cross past with you. And I never have. But I really am just, I admire you so much. And so this is exciting.
所以谢谢你这么说。我们很高兴见到你。我们是你的超级粉丝。我真的是你的超级粉丝。我一直希望在这些众多的行业活动中，我能和你擦肩而过。但我从来没有。但我真的很钦佩你。所以这很令人兴奋。
Same here. Your work has brought me so much joy. And again, like I wonder. I'm like, did everybody just say the same things? because you're just so significant to a large group of people. But truly, this is a frickin' trip, man. It really is for me. Well, we can't wait to talk to you.
我也是。你的作品给我带来了很多快乐。再说一次，我想知道。我在想，每个人是不是都说同样的话？因为你对一大群人来说意义重大。但真的，这太不可思议了，伙计。对我来说确实如此。好吧，我们迫不及待想和你聊天了。
And we kick off our show with a chit-chat suggestion from an Office Ladies fan. And we have one today from H. Let's hear from her. Hi, Office Ladies. A longtime listener here, big fan of the podcast. I have a chit-chat question for you. My husband and I just celebrated our one-year wedding anniversary. We bought our home just a couple months before we got married.
我们以一位《办公室女士》粉丝的闲聊建议开启我们的节目。我们今天有一位来自H的建议。让我们听听她的。嗨，《办公室女士》。我是长期听众，也是播客的超级粉丝。我有一个闲聊问题要问你们。我和我丈夫刚刚庆祝了我们结婚一周年纪念日。我们在结婚前几个月买了我们的房子。
So we've been nesting here for just over a year now. And when we moved in, I had the honor and privilege of deciding where all of the items in our kitchen belonged and found their home in place. It was a wonderful task that I thoroughly enjoyed getting to do. However, has caused some points of contention between my husband and I. in terms of where some items truly belong. An example of this has to do with the potato peeler. Now, I place items based on function. So the potato peeler for me goes in what I call the kitchen gadget or utility drawer.
所以我们在这里筑巢已经一年多了。当我们搬进来时，我有幸决定了厨房里所有物品的摆放位置，并为它们找到了家。这是一项我非常享受的美妙任务。然而，这导致了我和我丈夫之间的一些争论，关于某些物品真正属于哪里。这其中的一个例子与削皮刀有关。现在，我根据功能来放置物品。所以对我来说，削皮刀放在我所谓的厨房小工具或多功能抽屉里。
So this drawer houses items such as some measuring cups, my immersion blender. It has my lemon squeezer to squeeze out. the lemon juice, and other various items as such, kitchen utilities. Well, my husband likes to organize items based on, I guess, the material that they're made out of. And because a potato peeler has a blade, he likes to put it in the cutlery drawer where we house some of our knives. And every time I see it put there, I just have to take a deep breath and I move it just slightly back into the kitchen utility drawer. And so my question for you all is, what are some items in your house where it is a hill that you will die on in terms of where they are properly stored and organized in
所以这个抽屉里放着一些量杯、我的手持搅拌机。它有我的柠檬榨汁器来挤出柠檬汁，以及其他类似的物品，厨房用具。嗯，我丈夫喜欢根据物品的材质来整理它们。因为削皮刀有刀片，他喜欢把它放在我们放刀具的餐具抽屉里。每次我看到它被放在那里，我就不得不深呼吸，然后我把它稍微移回厨房多功能抽屉里。所以我想问你们所有人，在你们家里，有哪些物品的存放和整理位置是你们绝不妥协的？
your home? Whether it's another item in your kitchen or perhaps a different place inside your house, what are some items that is a strong hill for you? And perhaps maybe you've been challenged by either a spouse or a child in terms of where that item truly belongs. If I get a dinner rant out of this, that is a huge cherry on top, as I love hearing those from her, but I'm just looking forward to hearing your answers here. All right. Take care. Love you. Bye. That was such a detailed, thoughtful question. Very thorough. Very thorough. Yeah. Haley, it did make my blood boil several times. So you are correct. It brought some
无论是厨房里的另一件物品，还是家里其他地方，有哪些物品是你坚决捍卫的？也许你曾因为那件物品真正属于哪里而受到配偶或孩子的挑战。如果我能因此得到一段晚餐吐槽，那将是锦上添花，因为我喜欢听她讲这些，但我只是期待听到你们的回答。好的。保重。爱你们。再见。那是一个非常详细、深思熟虑的问题。非常彻底。非常彻底。是的。海莉，它确实让我几次血脉喷张。所以你是对的。它确实勾起了我个人的一些
things up for me personally, but I'll let you guys go first. I mean, Jenny, you're our guest. You get to go. How do you feel about where things are placed in the kitchen? Or home. Our home. Yeah, we can open this up. First of all, I really understand the predicament and the ongoing back and forth. And I'm the person that I love unpacking as well and I love moving. I know some people think that's freakish, but I really enjoy it. And I unpacked our whole kitchen when my family moved last, fall. And I get insecure about feeling controlling, but I cook every day. I cook a lot. I've been asked by family members to bake less. And I kind of feel like, I don't know, it's like if the person who unpacked it and placed it there kind of feels like that should sort of be where it lies. But the
事情，但我会让你们先说。我的意思是，珍妮，你是我们的嘉宾。你先请。你觉得厨房里的东西应该放在哪里？或者家里。我们的家。是的，我们可以讨论这个。首先，我非常理解这种困境和持续的来回。我也是那种喜欢拆包的人，我也喜欢搬家。我知道有些人认为这很怪异，但我真的很享受。我上次搬家时拆了我们整个厨房，那是去年秋天。我对自己感到控制欲强而感到不安，但我每天都做饭。我做饭很多。我被家人要求少烘焙一点。我有点觉得，我不知道，就像如果拆包并放置它的人觉得它应该放在那里，那它就应该放在那里。但
other thing I'll say is like, I don't really understand putting a potato peeler with blades. because I feel like it's just sort of a general utensil. I would just put it with the can opener is what I would say. Like utility, like she was saying. Yeah. Yeah. But I also don't really, I mean, this isn't a criticism of Haley, but I put all the baking things in one place.
我要说的另一件事是，我不太理解把削皮刀和刀片放在一起。因为我觉得它只是一种通用器具。我会把它和开罐器放在一起，这就是我会说的。就像多功能，就像她刚才说的那样。是的。是的。但我也不太，我的意思是，这不是对海莉的批评，但我把所有的烘焙用品都放在一个地方。
But that's because I really need them to be separate because I use them a lot. But you know what mine is? For me, it's the screen door, which I know is not necessarily an object or item that you might think of, but it's like, I need that to be shut. And it's not getting shut. Yeah. Yeah. It's crazy to me.
但那是因为我真的需要它们分开，因为我经常使用它们。但你知道我的是什么吗？对我来说，是纱门，我知道这不一定是你可能想到的物体或物品，但就像，我需要它关上。但它没关上。是的。是的。这让我很疯狂。
I don't understand why you would leave it open when the whole point of it is to shut it so that you don't get bugs in the house. Yeah. It kills me. Yeah. I love that. I mean, here's the thing. Jenna knows this. Jenny, I am not the cook in my house.
我不明白为什么你会把它敞开，因为它的全部意义就是关上它，这样你就不会让虫子进屋。是的。这让我抓狂。是的。我喜欢这个。我的意思是，事情是这样的。珍娜知道这一点。珍妮，我不是家里做饭的人。
My husband's a baker and a chef. And he bakes a ton. So he has his baking area. The kitchen really makes sense to him. It's like, you know, that scene in Goodwill hunting where there's all the equations on the chalkboard. And he's like, I just see it. I just see it. I just see it.
我丈夫是烘焙师和厨师。他烘焙很多。所以他有他的烘焙区。厨房对他来说真的很有意义。就像，你知道《心灵捕手》里黑板上写满方程式的那一幕吗？他说，我只是看到了。我只是看到了。我只是看到了。
That's how Josh is about the kitchen. I'm like, I don't get it. I don't understand why the seasoning needs to go here. And he's like, how can you not? So I'm probably the wrong person to ask this question because I'll just be like, if you want the forks to go there and that's important for you, the forks will go there, damn it. But for me, it's he doesn't shut a single cabinet.
乔什对厨房就是这样。我说，我不明白。我不明白为什么调料需要放在这里。他说，你怎么会不明白？所以我可能不是问这个问题的合适人选，因为我只会说，如果你想让叉子放在那里，这对你很重要，那叉子就放在那里，该死。但对我来说，是他从来不关任何橱柜。
You got to shut those. No cabinets. No, I'm like, I just walked through like Vana White. I'm just shutting things all day. I'm like, why? The dishwasher this morning, he just left it open. He left it open. I'm like, I don't get it. Someone's going to fall and like chip a tooth. It's like there's a ghost. That's how it feels to me when the cabinets are open. It's like a ghost came in and they were like, I just need you to know I'm still here. And so they left like a cabin open. Shut it, man. Just shut it already. All right, Jenna, what about you? Okay, I know what mine is. So in our kitchen, by our back door, we have, it's called the junk drawer, but I don't like it to be called that because to me, it is our highly organized miscellaneous drawer. And so I need three things to be in this drawer. And my husband and I only agree about one of them. And this is a sort of thing, like when I open this drawer and one of my items, one of my three essentials is not in the drawer, I have to take
你得关上那些。没有橱柜。不，我就像，我只是像凡娜·怀特一样走来走去。我整天都在关东西。我说，为什么？今天早上洗碗机，他只是把它敞开着。他把它敞开着。我说，我不明白。有人会摔倒，磕掉一颗牙。就像有鬼一样。当橱柜打开时，我就是这种感觉。就像鬼进来了，他们说，我只是想让你知道我还在。所以他们留下了一个橱柜打开。关上它，伙计。快关上它。好吧，珍娜，你呢？好的，我知道我的是什么。所以在我们的厨房里，在后门旁边，我们有，它被称为杂物抽屉，但我不喜欢它被称为那个，因为对我来说，它是我们高度整理的杂项抽屉。所以我需要三样东西放在这个抽屉里。我和我丈夫只同意其中之一。这是一种，就像当我打开这个抽屉，我的三件必需品之一不在抽屉里时，我必须深呼吸，提醒自己他是个好人，他做了很多美妙的事情。
deep breaths and like remind myself that he's a good man and he does so many wonderful things. And he loves me very much. So that I don't, you know, go off. Here's what I need in that drawer. I need band-aids because it's the first step. Like if you're outside and you skin a knee, this is as soon as you walk in the house, this is the closest drawer to that skinned knee. So I need band-aids in there. We agree on this. Band-Aids live there. Here are the other two things I need in there. I need a measuring tape. My husband thinks the measuring tape goes in the garage. The garage is not attached to our house.
而且他非常爱我。这样我就不会，你知道，发火。这是我需要放在那个抽屉里的东西。我需要创可贴，因为这是第一步。就像如果你在外面擦伤了膝盖，这是你一进屋，离那个擦伤的膝盖最近的抽屉。所以我需要创可贴在里面。我们对此达成了一致。创可贴住在那儿。这是我需要的另外两样东西。我需要一把卷尺。我丈夫认为卷尺应该放在车库里。车库没有连接到我们的房子。
It's far. It's not. That's too far. I like to measure things. I measure things more often than maybe you would think. I'm constantly wondering like, oh, could we put this picture here or could we move a chair here and I measure? I'm a pre-measure. I don't just move stuff.
很远。不是。那太远了。我喜欢测量东西。我测量东西的频率可能比你想象的要高。我经常想，哦，我们可以把这张照片放在这里吗，或者我们可以把椅子移到这里吗，然后我就测量。我是预先测量。我不只是移动东西。
So I need my measuring tape there. I didn't know any of this about her, Jenny. We've been friends a long time. I didn't know band-aids and measuring tape go in the same drawer. Okay, go. The other thing that I need in there is packing tape. Again, my husband is always putting the measuring tape and the packing tape out in the garage. But you know what he puts in the drawer?
所以我需要我的卷尺在那里。我不知道关于她的任何这些，珍妮。我们认识很久了。我不知道创可贴和卷尺放在同一个抽屉里。好的，继续。我需要的另一件事是打包胶带。同样，我丈夫总是把卷尺和打包胶带放在车库里。但你知道他把什么放在抽屉里吗？
This is the thing where I feel like I look at him and I'm like, I don't know who you are. I don't understand you. He has like seven different screwdrivers and two. They don't go in the garage? Two needle nose plates. Thank you. Yeah. Thank you.
这就是我觉得我看着他，心想，我不知道你是谁。我不理解你。他有七把不同的螺丝刀和两把。它们不去车库吗？两把尖嘴钳。谢谢。是的。谢谢。
Two needle nose pliers. I just cleaned out the drawer again. And I said, babe, do we need both needle nose pliers in here? Like, when's the last time you were like, oh, I need some needle nose pliers and I need them quick? I need them to be really close, like in the kitchen. I mean, when did you use these last? And double. Did you have one in each hand?
两把尖嘴钳。我刚刚又清理了那个抽屉。我说，宝贝，我们需要把两把尖嘴钳都放在这里吗？就像，你上次说，哦，我需要一些尖嘴钳，而且我需要快点用到它们，是什么时候？我需要它们离得很近，就像在厨房里一样。我的意思是，你上次用这些是什么时候？而且是双份的。你一只手拿一把吗？
Exactly. They're the same size. One wasn't tinier than the other. And all the screwdrivers, I said similarly, like, how many of these screwdrivers are we using on a weekly basis? Zero. Yeah. I think that tools can be out in the garage, but the packing tape that I use on almost every other day and the measuring tape, because I love to measure, and the band-aids, we need those in the drawer. I want to throw this out there to you.
完全正确。它们是一样大的。一个并没有比另一个小。所有的螺丝刀，我也同样说，就像，我们每周使用多少把这些螺丝刀？零。是的。我认为工具可以放在车库里，但我几乎每隔一天就用的打包胶带，还有我喜欢测量的卷尺，以及创可贴，我们需要把它们放在抽屉里。我想把这个抛给你。
I'm Haley. Haley and I get along. Yeah, I mean, this is so funny how this question, like, really fired me up. I really want the things in my kitchen to stay where they are. I just want them to stay right where they are, especially the sponge. Oh, that's the other one. Is your sponge moving around? It's moving around.
我是海莉。海莉和我相处得很好。是的，我的意思是，这个问题真的让我很兴奋，这太搞笑了。我真的希望我厨房里的东西留在它们原来的地方。我只是希望它们留在原地，尤其是海绵。哦，那是另一个。你的海绵在到处移动吗？它在到处移动。
It's not getting squeezed out. I hate it when people leave it in the sink. I'm like, no. It's gross. Don't do that. Wait, always our sound engineer Sam and our producer Matt weigh in on this too. So Sam, what do you got? Nothing.
它没有被挤干。我讨厌人们把它留在水槽里。我说，不。这很恶心。别那样做。等等，我们的音响工程师萨姆和我们的制片人马特也对此发表了看法。所以萨姆，你有什么？没有。
I'm completely malleable. Move me. What? Sam. Wow. Nicasa, sukasa, yeah. Not attached to where things live. Nope.
我完全可以被塑造。移动我。什么？萨姆。哇。我的房子就是你的房子，是的。不执着于东西住在哪里。没有。
Okay. All right. Sounds healthy. It does. It sounds really zen. Matt Beagle. I grew up in a. a house where we put cups and glasses in a drawer. And people think that's really weird, but it's
好的。好的。听起来很健康。确实。听起来真的很禅。马特·比格尔。我在一个把杯子和玻璃杯放在抽屉里的房子里长大。人们认为这真的很奇怪，但这只是
just what I'm used to. So I like cups in a drawer, but that's unpopular, I think. Cups in a drawer is surprising because you don't think they're going to be there. Sometimes that's just what I'm used to this from childhood. I don't feel super strongly about it. It's just sort of like, I'm just got to use to it. I'm going to throw this out there. One more thing. I didn't really tell passionate I am about this stuff, especially since I'm someone who doesn't really care about kitchen things. But when the kids were little and we were like encouraging them to like help at dinner time set the table, we had these lower drawers in the kitchen that we put plates and cups in that were plastic. And they could then set their place at the table. And they got really excited about that.
我习惯的。所以我喜欢把杯子放在抽屉里，但我认为这并不受欢迎。把杯子放在抽屉里很令人惊讶，因为你不会想到它们会在那里。有时这只是我从小就习惯的。我对此感觉并不强烈。这只是，我只是习惯了。我想把这个抛出来。还有一件事。我没有真正告诉你们我对这些东西有多热情，尤其是因为我是一个不太关心厨房用品的人。但当孩子们还小的时候，我们鼓励他们在晚餐时间帮忙摆桌子，我们在厨房里有这些较低的抽屉，我们把塑料的盘子和杯子放在里面。然后他们就可以在桌子上摆放他们的位置。他们对此感到非常兴奋。
And now they're in high school. They're driving. They're teenagers. But they still want those cups and plates in the lower drawer because they use them for like, they grab them for snacks, like apple slices or. M&Ms or peanuts. And I know someday the lower drawer won't be full of the plastic cups in place. And I'm already like sad about it. I'm sorry, I have kids that are now seniors and Jenny, all this stuff is coming up. I'm like, someday there's not going to be the drawer. But lady, then you're going to be a grandma and it's going to be filled with all those.
现在他们上高中了。他们在开车。他们是青少年。但他们仍然想要那些放在较低抽屉里的杯子和盘子，因为他们用它们来，就像，他们拿它们吃零食，比如苹果片或M&Ms或花生。我知道总有一天较低的抽屉里不会再装满塑料杯和盘子。我已经为此感到难过了。对不起，我有现在是高年级的孩子，珍妮，所有这些事情都浮现出来了。我在想，总有一天不会有那个抽屉了。但是女士，那时你就会成为祖母了，它会被所有那些填满的。
Oh gosh. Not for a bit. Don't worry. Okay. Just keep them there. Yeah. All right. Well, Haley, thank you so much for sending in your question. You got a lot of strong feelings from a lot of people. Yeah, that was fun. All right. Well, listen, why don't we take a break? And then we're going to come back and we're going to talk more with Jenny. Yay! All right, you guys, we are back with Jenny Slate. And Jenny, you have a new animated movie coming out. It's called Forgotten Island.
哦，天哪。暂时不会。别担心。好的。只要把它们留在那里。是的。好的。好吧，海莉，非常感谢你寄来你的问题。你从很多人那里得到了很多强烈的感受。是的，那很有趣。好的。好吧，听着，我们为什么不休息一下呢？然后我们会回来，我们会和珍妮聊更多。耶！好的，各位，我们和珍妮·斯蕾特回来了。珍妮，你有一部新的动画电影要上映了。它叫《被遗忘的岛屿》。
It's in theaters now. Yes. Yes. It is. My character is, she's a spirit. And maybe not, you can't really tell. She good or bad. We will see.
它现在在影院上映。是的。是的。它是。我的角色是，她是一个灵魂。也许不是，你真的看不出来。她是好是坏。我们会看到的。
And somehow I'm always in that. I get put in that zone a lot of like playing the problematic person. The baddie. Same, same, Jenny. Right, of course. It's very opposite of how I see myself. Like, maybe the first time it happened was on the Kroll show, where Nick Kroll and I were playing these kind of, like, silly women who are both named Liz.
不知何故，我总是处于那种状态。我经常被放在那个区域，扮演有问题的人。坏蛋。一样，一样，珍妮。对，当然。这和我看待自己的方式完全相反。就像，也许第一次发生是在《克罗尔秀》上，我和尼克·克罗尔扮演这些，就像，愚蠢的女人，她们都叫莉兹。
You're like idiots. But then they, like, ratcheted it up on Parks and Rec with Mona Lisa, who's described as the worst person in the world. Oh, my gosh. That is one of my favorite characters, Mona Lisa. You and Ben Schwartz together. It's so cool. I love it.
你就像白痴。但后来他们，就像，在《公园与游憩》中用莫娜·丽莎加剧了这一点，她被描述为世界上最糟糕的人。哦，天哪。那是我的最爱角色之一，莫娜·丽莎。你和本·施瓦茨在一起。太酷了。我喜欢它。
But anyway, in Forgotten Island, the character I play Batiba, she's very cute and sweet and lonely. And in general, the movie is really funny and quite beautiful. I'm like a big animation fan, so it's, I don't know. It's very magical. Like there's these two best friends and they fall through this portal and they get stuck on this forgotten island. And it's visually just beautiful and so colorful. And the creatures they encounter are otherworldly and really cool looking. Yeah.
但无论如何，在《被遗忘的岛屿》中，我扮演的角色巴蒂巴，她非常可爱、甜美且孤独。总的来说，这部电影非常有趣且相当美丽。我是一个动画大粉丝，所以，我不知道。它非常神奇。就像有两个最好的朋友，他们掉进了这个传送门，被困在这个被遗忘的岛屿上。它在视觉上非常美丽，色彩斑斓。他们遇到的生物是超凡脱俗的，看起来非常酷。是的。
It's a total trip, not just into like the imagination, but it's a very interesting metaphor for what it's like to move from your teenage years into like the world at large and like adulthood. And will you hold on to your childhood relationships? And these are things that I'm constantly fascinated by. And also like, and my character, as I said, is like she's really lonely and afraid to go outside. And I don't know why I became this way. but I've always been really concerned with like, how do you make those things,
这绝对是一次旅行，不仅是进入想象力，而且它是关于从青少年时期进入广阔世界和成年期是什么样子的一个非常有趣的隐喻。你会坚持你的童年关系吗？这些是我一直着迷的事情。而且，我的角色，正如我所说，她真的很孤独，害怕出门。我不知道为什么我变成了这样。但我一直非常关心，就像，你如何让那些事情，
not something we laugh at, but something that can make us laugh so we can kind of get enough relief so that we can like find better options for how to deal with it. Yeah, yeah, or have empathy, right? And be like, oh, I remember a time like that in my life too. Yeah. Yeah.
不是我们嘲笑的东西，而是可以让我们发笑的东西，这样我们就可以得到足够的缓解，以便我们可以找到更好的选择来处理它。是的，是的，或者有同理心，对吧？然后说，哦，我也记得我生命中那样的时刻。是的。是的。
I'm really excited to see this movie with my daughter. She's starting middle school. And similar to this movie, I mean, the characters are a little older in this movie, that one of them is going off to college. But like, my daughter's entering middle school and there's a lot of new friendships that are formed and friend groups shift and, you know, who was your best friend from kindergarten might not actually end up being your best friend when you graduate as a senior. And so I think that's a really
我真的很兴奋能和我的女儿一起看这部电影。她刚上初中。和这部电影类似，我的意思是，这部电影里的角色稍微大一点，其中一个要去上大学。但就像，我的女儿刚上初中，有很多新的友谊形成，朋友圈发生变化，你知道，你在幼儿园最好的朋友可能实际上最终不会成为你毕业时最好的朋友。所以我认为这是这部电影非常酷的一部分，就是友谊是如何移动和过渡的。是的。是的。是的。就像我和我的女儿一起看很多动画片，她五岁。我认为对她来说看这部电影不会太可怕。但我也认为，就像我的侄子和侄女，他们年纪大一点，就像他们是高中生，我认为他们会非常喜欢它。这对我来说就像是一种得分，我可以带他们去看一部我参演的电影。哦，巨大的。是的。是的。你给你的女儿看过你配音的其他动画电影吗？我看过。她似乎觉得《疯狂动物城》太可怕了，我理解。五岁时，我明白这一点。是的。她就像害怕冲突，我们不都这样吗，你知道。她有点害怕《爱宠大机密》，因为狗一开始相处得不好。她认为那太艰难了。但就像，奇怪的是，她喜欢《头脑特工队》。就像，当有人处于情感挣扎中时，她就像，我能理解，我会插上电源。但当有人只是像，我不希望你在这里时，她太伤心了，我有点像，那太棒了。但她看过《老雷斯的故事》。我是《老雷斯的故事》里的妈妈，也由你的联合主演艾德·赫尔姆斯主演。是的。艾德·赫尔姆斯，他是我的挚友，每年感恩节都会来。我喜欢那个。我的孩子们实际上是，好吧，听着，他们现在是青少年了，他们非常兴奋我能见到你，因为他们认为你很酷，对吧？我不，我不酷，但你很酷。
cool part of this movie is just how friendships move and transition. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Like I watch a lot of animated stuff with my daughter and she's five. And I think it won't be too. scary for her to see. But I also think like my nieces and nephews who are older, like their high schoolers, I think they'll really enjoy it. That's like kind of a score for me that I can take them to a movie that I'm in. Oh, huge. Yeah. Yeah. Have you shown your daughter any of the other animated films that you have voiced a character for? I have. She appears to find Zootopia to be too scary, which I understand. At five, I get that. Yeah. She's like it's scared of like conflict, which don't we all, you know. And she's a little bit afraid of the secret life of pets because the dogs don't get
但他们确实说，你知道，他们显然知道你很多作品，因为他们现在大了，但他们说有一部电影是循环播放的，因为我们有它的DVD。我们有那辆小型货车，上面有那种折叠的小电影，你在公路旅行时会把DVD放进去。他们一遍又一遍地看《鼠来宝3》。所以他们就像，哦，天哪，你会告诉她我们爱她在《鼠来宝3》里的表现吗？所以我答应他们我会告诉你。好吧，那我说谢谢。那是我认为我参演的第一部电影。
along at first. And she thinks that's too tough. But like, weirdly, she's into inside out. Like, when is someone in an emotional struggle, she's like, I can understand, I'll plug in. But when it's someone just being like, I don't want you to be here, she hurts her feelings too much, which I'm kind of like, that's great. But she has seen the Lorax. I was the mom in the Lorax, also starring your co-star, Ed Helms. Yes. Ed Helms, who is one of my dear friends and comes for Thanksgiving every year. I love that. My kids actually were, well, listen, they're teenagers now and they're very excited that I'm meeting you because they think you're cool, right? And I don't, I'm not cool, but you're cool.
再说一次，你就像坏蛋。我知道。这只是很奇怪。也许它说的是，我真的忘了。那部电影很狂野。就像，我不完全记得情节。但我有点觉得我在模仿汤姆·汉克斯和《荒岛余生》。是的，你是。
But they did say, you know, they obviously know a lot of your credits because they're older now, but they're like one movie that was on repeat because we had the DVD of it. And we had the minivan with like the fold down little movie that you'd put the DVD in on road trips. They watched Alvin and the Chipmunks chip wrecked over and over. And so they were like, oh my gosh, will you tell her we loved her and Alvin and the Chipmunks Chipprect. And so I promised him I would tell you that. Well, then I said thank you. That was, I think, my first movie I was ever in.
我对制作那部电影的记忆就像，我以前从未拍过电影，从我。是的，我想那是我的第一部。我被《周六夜现场》解雇了。我在想，我怎么才能找到工作？然后有这部电影，《鼠来宝》，我心想，酷，太棒了。然后我也从未和绿幕或任何特效合作过。就像花栗鼠不在那里。对。
And again, you're like the baddie. I know. It's just like weird. Maybe it says that is, I forgot, honestly. That movie is wild. Like, I don't exactly remember the plot. but I kind of feel like I'm spoofing Tom Hanks and castaway. Yes, you are.
对于那个，它们不是真的。而且那已经是我生命中一个敏感的时期，因为我在想，你知道，就像，我还会再演戏吗？就像，发生了什么？然后我只是，制作这部电影真的非常有趣。而且我在温哥华的一个工作室里，对着棍子上的网球说话。
My memory of making that movie is like, I'd never made a movie before from what I. Yeah, I think it was my first. And I had like been fired from SNL. I was like, how am I going to get a job? And then there's this movie, Elvin and the Chitmunks, I'm like, cool, great. And then I'd never also worked with like a green screen or any special effects. And like the Chimunks aren't there. Right.
我希望这在表演中没有表现出来。不，一点也不。你完全卖力了。然后我们在夏威夷待了几周。我的父母来看我，只是为了确保我，就像，还好。好吧，你从夏威夷得到了一次免费旅行。从中，这总是很有趣，当一部电影或项目带你去某个酷的地方时。我知道。
For that, they're not real. And it already was like, a sensitive time in my life because I was like, you know, like, am I ever going to act again? Like, what happened? And then I just like, making the movie was genuinely very fun. And it was a lot of me in like a studio in Vancouver talking to like a tennis ball on a stick.
哦，是的。天哪，那真是一个加分项。这一切都是一个梦。就像，我不知道你在娱乐行业的经历是什么，但就像，对我来说，它还没有消失。它只是没有消失，我心想，这太酷了。是的。是的。
I hope that doesn't show in the performance. No, not at all. You totally sell it. And then we had like a few weeks in Hawaii. And my parents came to visit just to make sure that I was like, okay. Well, you got a free trip out of Hawaii. out of it, which is always fun when a movie or a project takes you somewhere cool. I know.
好吧，你做了很多事情，珍妮。我的意思是，你是一名演员，但你也是一名喜剧演员，但你也写过书，但你现在也是一名播客主持人。我很好奇。带我回到开始。就像，你在哪里长大的？在什么时刻你意识到我想成为一名艺人？
Oh, yeah. God, that's such a plus. It's all a dream. Like, I don't know what your experience of being in the entertainment industry is, but like, for me, it just has not worn off. It just hasn't worn off that I'm like, this is so cool. Yeah. Yeah.
好吧，我来自马萨诸塞州的米尔顿，那是波士顿以南六英里。那是我的家人来自的地方。我有两个姐妹。我的父母都是艺术家。我妈妈是陶艺家，我爸爸是诗人。我们会从图书馆租电影。你知道，就像我爸爸的一个朋友
Well, you've done so many things, Jenny. I mean, you are an actress, but you're also a comedian, but you've also written books, but you also are now a podcaster. I'm very curious. Take me back to the beginning. Like, where did you grow up? And at what point did you realize I want to be an entertainer?
给我们弄了一台录像机。我们从图书馆租电影。我真的记不起我不想要成为一名演员的时候了。我真的，真的想要。这很大程度上是基于观看朱迪·加兰和吉恩·凯利，但也包括《芝麻街》电影，比如《跟随那只鸟》。如果有人记得那部电影，它太棒了。还有像秀兰·邓波儿，我不确定那些电影是否经得起时间的考验，我也不确定我是否能推荐它们。也许不再是最敏感、最合适的电影了。但在当时，就像，我主要是喜欢她是一个小女孩，她有踢踏舞鞋，她就像有一个大棒棒糖。我只是，是的，我一直想成为一名表演者。但我的父母，他们就像，你可以在学校里做那个。就像你可以参加戏剧之类的。
Well, I'm from Milton, Massachusetts, which is six miles south of Boston. And that's where my family is from. And I have two sisters. My parents are both artists. My mom is a potter and my dad is a poet. And we would like rent movies from the library. You know, like one of my dad's friends
我参加了演讲队。我在我们的演讲和辩论队。但他们只是说，在你上大学之前你不会做那个。这是一种默契。我并没有真正意识到，就像有轨道，你知道，就像这个人是喜剧演员或者这个人做戏剧表演。我有点以为你可以做所有事情，因为也有做那些事情的演员，比如卡罗尔·伯内特，例如。是的。就像我真的非常喜欢她。对我来说，就像她在《安妮》中扮演汉尼根小姐真的很可怕。
got us a VCR. And we rented movies from the library. And I really can't remember a time that I didn't want to be an actor. I really, really wanted to. And a lot of that was based off of watching, Judy Garland and Gene Kelly, but also Sesame Street movies, like, follow that bird. If anyone remembers that movie was so good. And like Shirley Temple, which I'm not sure those films have aged well, and I'm not sure I could recommend them. Maybe not the most sensitive, appropriate films anymore. But at the time it was like, mostly I just liked that she was a little girl and she had tap shoes and she like had a big lollipop. And I just, yeah, I always wanted to be a performer. But my parents, they were like, you can do that in school. Like you can be in the plays and stuff.
是的。我真的很戏剧化。而且，是的，我从来没有想到你可能必须把它分开。我的人生梦想之一是参加《周六夜现场》。我看了吉尔达·拉德纳的所有录像带，我迷上了吉尔达·拉德纳。我去了哥伦比亚大学。我毕业了，开始和我的好朋友盖比·莱德曼一起做单口相声。那就是，就像，我的职业生涯开始的方式。
And I did speech team. I was on our speech and debate team. But they were just like, you're not going to do that until you go to college. It was kind of understood. And I didn't really realize like that there were tracks, you know, like this person is a comedian or this person does dramatic acting. I kind of thought you could just do everything because there also were actors that did that, like Carol Burnett, for example. Yeah. Like I just like I really loved her so much. And for me, like her playing Miss Hannigan and Annie was like really scary.
就像，我找了一个经理，他帮我接广告。你最早的广告之一是什么？因为那是我的路线。我做了很多广告。所以我喜欢看到人们在旧广告里。首先，我没有接很多。你有没有接过那些被称为，就像，工业广告的？哦，是的。
Yeah. I'm really dramatic. And yeah, I never occurred to me that you might have to separate it out. And one of my life's dreams was to be on Saturday Night Live. I watched like all the tapes of Gilda Radner and I was obsessed with Gilda Radner. and I went to Columbia. I graduated and started doing stand-up with my best friend, Gabe Leidman. And that's, like, kind of how my career started.
哦，是的。我做了一个。就像很多那种。是的。我做了一个，就像，我想。我想是为福特做的。我不得不谈论，就像，我不知道，那是引擎里的东西。而且就像，哦，我太糟糕了。真的很糟糕。是的。我的意思是，我觉得广告真的很难。而且你经常必须像，就像，对某件不那么令人兴奋的事情表现得非常正常。
Like, I got a manager who helped me get commercials. What was one of your earliest commercials? Because that was my route. I did tons of commercials. And so I love seeing people in old commercials. First of all, I didn't book a lot. Did you ever book those that were called, like, industrial? Oh, yeah.
你知道，就像如果你是，就像，你作为你自己在代言你真正使用的牙刷，这我已经做过了。我心想，我喜欢这个牙刷。作为珍妮，我真的很喜欢它对我的牙齿。但就像，我记得做了一个Cascade广告。那是我真正记得的。而且因为我永远无法理解的原因，他们给了我超长的接发。而且，我没有洗碗机。你知道，就像，我在布鲁克林的一个小公寓里。我没有洗碗机。而且就像，我用过的那个就像我父母的洗碗机。就像，那非常旧。而且我没有，就像，我以前从未使用过像豆荚一样的东西。我只是，我记得整天都在想，我搞砸了。我不知道怎么做这个。
Oh, yeah. I did one. Like a lot of that. Yeah. I did one for, like, I think. think it was for Ford. And I had to talk about like the, I don't know, it was something in the engine. And it was like, oh, I was so bad. It was really bad. Yeah. I mean, I feel like commercials are genuinely very hard. And you have to be like so normal often about something that's not very
那太棒了。是的，但这是一种在我做单口相声时赚钱的好方法。我得到的任何东西的第一次试镜，我相信是节目《凡人烦人》，由杰森·舒瓦兹曼和泰德·丹森和扎克·加利凡纳基斯主演。那就像我的第一份工作。哇。
exciting. You know, like it's one thing if you're like, you're you as you endorsing a toothbrush that you actually use, which I have done. And I'm like, I love this toothbrush. I really like it for my teeth as Jenny. But like, I remember doing a cascade commercial. That's the one I really remember. And that for reasons that I'll never understand, they gave me super long extensions. And also, I didn't have a dishwasher. You know, like, I was like a tiny apartment in Brooklyn. I didn't have a dishwasher. And like, the one I had used was like my parents dishwasher. Like, that was very old. And I didn't, like, I'd never used like a pod before. I just, I remember the whole day being like, I am so busted. I don't know how to do this.
是的。所以在那个时候，就像杰森·舒瓦兹曼和泰德·丹森是泰德·丹森和杰森·舒瓦兹曼，但扎克·加利凡纳基斯还在上升，对吧？是的，我相信那是《宿醉1》出来的前一年。是的。是的。所以我很好奇，我和其中一些人一起工作过，他们太有才华了，你走进片场，就像，那是什么样的？
That's amazing. Yeah, but it was a good way to make money while I was doing stand-up. And my first audition for anything, I believe that I got was the show Bored to Death, which starred Jason Schwartzman and Ted Danson and Zach Galfinacus. And that was like my first job. Wow.
你记得吗？我肯定记得，因为，首先，我最好的朋友嫁给了扎克，我没有告诉他们我正在为那个节目试镜，因为我，我只是感到尴尬。首先，我不太喜欢寻求帮助，我想。我只是，而且我不知道，就像，如果我很糟糕怎么办？然后我不确定他们是否能帮我进入节目，但我只是，就像，哦，我得到了这个角色。现在我实际上必须奇怪地告诉他们，就像我出现在扎克的工作场所。而且它就像，它本应该只是，就像我要扮演这个收银员，这是一个较小的部分。然后他们把它变大了，因为它实际上
Yeah. So at that time, like Jason Schwartzman and Ted Danson were Ted Danson and Jason Schwartson, but Zach Galefenakis was still kind of coming up, right? Yeah, I believe it was the year before the Hangover one came out. Yeah. Yeah. So I'm just curious, I've worked with a few of those guys, and they're so talented, and you walk on the set, like, what was that like?
太有趣了，进行得非常顺利，这就像，就像每个演员的梦想。但我只是记得，就像，你知道，我是杰森的超级粉丝。而且我来自波士顿。就像泰德·丹森，干杯。我的意思是，是的。这太疯狂了。我只是记得心想，什么都别说。
Do you remember? I would definitely remember because, first of all, my best friend is married to Zach, and I didn't tell them that I was auditioning for the show because I was, I just felt embarrassed. First of all, I don't really like asking for favors, I guess. I just, and I don't know, like, what if I was bad? And then I'm not sure they could have helped me get on the show, but I just like, I was like, oh, I got this part. Now I actually have to tell them weirdly that I'm like showing up at Zach's job. And it was like, it was supposed to be only like I was going to play this cashier and it was a smaller part. And then they made it bigger because it actually
什么都别做。什么都别说。只要做你的台词，就像，只要别奇怪，你知道吗？而那个计划，就像一个糟糕的计划。我甚至不知道这说明了我对自己有什么看法。但最终发生的事情是，
was so fun and went very well, which is like kind of at every actor's dream. But I just remember like, you know, I was a huge Jason fan. And I'm from Boston. Like Ted Danson, cheers. I mean, yeah. It's just crazy. And I just remember being like, just don't say anything.
我太，太，太，太紧张了。但当我开始和杰森交谈的那一秒，他非常友善和友好，紧张感变成了完全的兴奋，就像，我实际上在那里。你知道，我有点期待有人会像，滚出去。就像球场上的粉丝，你知道，就像，把她赶出去。
Just don't do anything. Don't say anything. Just do your lines and like, just don't be weird, you know? And that plan, which is like a terrible plan. I don't even know what that says about what I thought of myself. But what ended up happening was like,
就像，为什么这个人在这里？我只是记得，就像，有那种真正的梦幻感觉，就像，哇，我实际上穿过了窗帘进入了梦境。而且我是节目里的演员之一。而且，就像，没人知道我不知道任何行话。就像，有人就像，所以这是你的标记？就像，我不知道电视场景里的人
I was so, so, so, so nervous. But the second I started talking to Jason, who's very kind and friendly, the nervousness changed to total excitement that, like, I was actually there. You know, I kind of expected someone to be like, get out. Like, fan on the field, you know, just like, get her out of here.
不仅仅是随心所欲地走来走去。我从来没有在摄像机前，除了，就像，工作室里的Cascade广告，他们只是把我放在洗碗机前，我只是打开它。你知道，就像，我真的不知道我在做什么。我不知道我的标记是什么。我不知道什么是覆盖。我不知道，就像，
Like, why is this person here? And I just remember, like, having the real dreamy feeling, like, wow, I've actually crossed through the curtain into the dreamscape. and I'm one of the actors on the show. And, like, nobody knows that I don't know any of the lingo. Like, someone was like, so this is your mark? Like, I didn't know that people in a scene on TV
好的，就像这是你对话的一面，摄像机对着你。你必须做你的，就像，如果你不寻找交叉谈话，你不一定能打断。就像，我不知道我在做什么。每个人都对我非常好，非常好。而且那是一个真正的高潮。就像，它只是感觉很疯狂。我有点不敢相信。而且老实说，当我回想起来时，我仍然觉得这只是一个伟大的运气，你知道吗？我的意思是，很多都感觉是那样，对吧？我的意思是，就像只是在正确的时间出现在正确的地方。但同时，你也做了工作。就像，这不是偶然的，但它是。你知道我的意思吗？这有点难描述，因为就像所有的事情都排成一行。你必须出现。你必须做好工作。但
don't just walk around wherever they want. I never been on camera other than, like, a cascade commercial in a studio where they just put me in front of the dishwasher and I just opened it. You know, like, I genuinely had no idea what I was doing. I didn't know what my mark was. And I didn't know what coverage was. I didn't know, like,
我总是想到这一点，特别是在即兴表演和与这么多才华横溢的人一起表演时，他们从来没有得到所有事情排成一行的那种，而且他们太有才华了，你知道吗？根本没有短期的赌注。就像我可以做所有这些，而它只是也许没有按照我的方式进行。而且我感觉非常意识到。这一点仍然存在。我大学毕业时没有像五年计划那样的东西，但回想起来也许我应该有。我知道。我没有后备计划。我认为有时那可能是一件好事。你知道我的意思吗？我知道。是的。我认为没有安全网在追求艺术生活时可能是好的。在你职业生涯早期，有没有一个风险，你特别
okay, like this is your side of the conversation, the camera's on you. You have to do your, like, you can't interrupt necessarily if they're not looking for cross talk. Like, I did not know what I was doing. And everybody was really, really nice to me. And it was a real high. Like, it just felt crazy. I kind of couldn't believe it. And honestly, when I think back on it now, I still feel like it's just a great stroke of luck, you know? I mean, so much of it feels that way, right? I mean, it's like just being in the right place at the right time. But also, you had done the work. Like, it's not by chance, but it is. Do you know what I mean? It's kind of hard to describe because like all the things line up. You have to show up. You have to do a good job. But
得到了回报？哦。是的。我想是的。我的意思是，一切都是风险。就像在，我，我，一切就像仍然是风险。你知道，有一个，我认为回想起来我像，我会只是戴上这个假发走出去，就像，如此不自觉，这有点尴尬。但我认为产生最大影响的风险可能是拍摄电影《显然怀了孕》，那是我参演的第一部电影之一，也许是第三部。而且那是一部真正的独立电影，就像真正的独立，独立，独立。就像我们在制片人的房子里拍摄。
I always think about that, especially coming up and improv and performing with just so many amazingly talented people who never got that lineup of all the things lining up and they're so talented, you know? There's just no short bets at all. Like I could have done all of that and it just maybe didn't go my way. And I feel very aware. of that still. I didn't have like a five-year plan coming out of college, but maybe I should have looking back. I know. I didn't have a backup plan. I think sometimes that's maybe a good thing. Do you know what I mean? I do. Yeah. I think not having a safety net can be good when you're pursuing an artistic life. Was there a risk that you took early in your career that particularly
我总是会想到这一点，特别是在我刚起步、做即兴表演，与那么多才华横溢却始终没能迎来机遇的人共事时，他们真的非常有才华，你知道吗？这行根本没有稳赚不赔的买卖。我可能做了所有该做的事，但结果就是没能如愿。我至今对此仍有很深的感触。我大学毕业时并没有什么五年计划，但回过头来看，也许我应该有的。我知道。我当时没有备选方案。我觉得有时候这反而是件好事。你明白我的意思吗？我明白。是的。我认为在追求艺术生涯时，没有退路有时反而是一件好事。在你职业生涯早期，有没有哪次冒险是特别
paid off? Ooh. Yeah. I think so. I mean, everything is risk. Like at the, I, I'm everything like still is risk. You know, there's a, I think it's kind of embarrassing to look back on the ways that I was like, I'll just put on this wig and get out there and like, just so unselfconscious. But I think the risk that had like the most effect was probably doing the movie obvious child, which was like one of the first films I was in, maybe it was like the third. And it was a real indie, like a real indie indie, indie. Like we are filming in the producer's house.
有回报的？噢。有的。我想是有的。我的意思是，一切都是冒险。就像在……我，我的一切，现在依然是冒险。你知道，回想我当时那种“我就戴上这顶假发走上台”的样子，那种毫无顾忌的状态，现在想来还有点尴尬。但我觉得影响最大的冒险，可能就是出演电影《小脚趾》（Obvious Child），那是我参演的第一批电影之一，大概是第三部吧。那是一部真正的独立电影，非常、非常、非常独立。我们甚至是在制片人的家里拍摄的。
I'm wearing the director's clothes. are just very, very little money. And I mean, now it's even a, I think like the conversation is incredibly different because reproductive justice and abortion rights are so restricted. But at the time, it was like, I still was like, oh, this is a movie about a comedian who gets an abortion and it's not joking about abortion. It's taking women's health seriously, but it's still really funny. And I just felt like, whoa, like, who knows what this will be like and who knows what these,
我穿着导演的衣服。钱真的非常非常少。我是说，现在情况完全不同了，我觉得对话的内容也大不相同，因为生殖正义和堕胎权受到了极大的限制。但在当时，我还是觉得，哦，这是一部关于一个做了堕胎手术的喜剧演员的电影，它并不是在拿堕胎开玩笑。它严肃对待女性健康，但依然非常有趣。我当时就觉得，哇，谁知道这会是什么样，谁知道这些……
who these people are that I'm working with. And it just was so small. I genuinely did it because I wanted to do dramatic work. And it came to me, I had done the short film of it, which I don't feel like it was a big risk. That was just kind of like, it's fun and it's normal and it's small. But I didn't really know what I was doing. I didn't know how to do a dramatic scene.
我合作的这些人是谁。而且这部片子规模真的很小。我真心实意地拍它是因为我想尝试戏剧表演。这个机会找上我时，我已经拍过它的短片版了，我觉得那不算什么大冒险。那更像是，这很有趣，很正常，规模也很小。但我当时真的不知道自己在做什么。我不知道该怎么演一场戏剧性的戏。
I didn't go to like acting school. And I, yeah, I think like the biggest risk for me was like, I've always thought I could do this. What if I get there and I find out that I was completely wrong? You know, like that seems that it could happen. And instead it, you know, the people that I made that film with, they became my best friends. They've directed and produced all of my comedy specials and I've worked with them many times over. And Liz who produced that film and she also produced Marcel the Shell Shoes on the movie.
我没上过表演学校。而且，是的，我觉得对我来说最大的风险是，我一直以为我能演好。万一我到了现场，发现自己完全错了呢？你知道，这看起来是有可能发生的。但结果是，你知道，和我一起拍那部电影的人成了我最好的朋友。他们执导并制作了我所有的喜剧特辑，我和他们合作过很多次。还有制作那部电影的莉兹，她也制作了《穿着鞋子的贝壳马塞尔》这部电影。
And it just paid off in so many social and professional ways for sure. Well, that is the movie that put you on my radar. Oh, really? Yes. Yes. I absolutely loved that movie. And you definitely delivered. You won a Critics Choice Award for it.
它确实在社交和职业层面上带来了很多回报。嗯，那部电影确实让我注意到了你。哦，真的吗？是的。是的。我非常喜欢那部电影。你表现得非常出色。你还因此获得了评论家选择奖。
That's true. Best actress in a comedy. Yeah. Jenna, I do remember you getting in touch with me about it, I think. Maybe it was on Instagram or like maybe we had an exchange. But I actually do remember being like, I think that she likes our movie. I might have slid into your DMs.
那是真的。最佳喜剧女演员。是的。珍娜，我确实记得你因为那部电影联系过我，我想。可能是在Instagram上，或者我们有过交流。但我确实记得当时心想，我觉得她喜欢我们的电影。我可能私信过你。
You know, Jake Lacey from the office is in that movie. Yeah. And he had told me about it. And I was like, I got to see this movie. It sounds so interesting. And it is. And it's all the things you said. It's a really grounded, cool conversation.
你知道，《办公室》里的杰克·莱西也演了那部电影。是的。他跟我提起过。我就想，我一定要看这部电影。听起来很有趣。确实很有趣。它包含了你所说的所有特质。这是一部非常扎实、很酷的对话电影。
But then also really, really funny. And you gave the character just, oh, God, she was just so real. I love that movie. Yeah. I'm glad. You just saw such humanity, you know, in your performance. You were so honest. And it was really beautiful.
但同时又非常、非常有趣。你赋予了这个角色，哦，天哪，她真的太真实了。我爱那部电影。是的，我很高兴。你在表演中展现了如此多的人性，你知道吗？你非常真诚。那真的很美。
And when we knew you were going to come on the podcast, both Jenna and Matt were like, and you have to see Obvious Child. And I was like, okay, that's the one I hadn't seen. And it is really wonderful. It's the best movie ever. It's so, I really just one of my favorites. Yeah. I'm so glad.
当我们知道你要来参加播客时，珍娜和马特都说，你一定要看《小屁孩》。我就说，好吧，那是唯一一部我还没看过的。它真的很棒。这是有史以来最好的电影。它太……我真的很喜欢，它是我的最爱之一。是的，我太高兴了。
I love that movie. You're great at it. We gosh. Thank you. I do want to take us back, though, to 2010 because how I first got to know you was Marcel, the Shelf, the Shoes on. And I watched all of them. I mean, my friends and I would like, like send them.
我爱那部电影。你演得太棒了。天哪。谢谢。不过，我想带大家回到2010年，因为我最初认识你是因为《穿着鞋子的贝壳马塞尔》。我把它们全看了。我是说，我和朋友们会互相转发。
Like, there was a line. Oh, it's something. Do you want to know how I put my skis on top of my car? And you're like, with a hair. I don't know. You guys, I'm doing horrible. I'm like doing you to you. This is so embarrassing.
比如，里面有一句台词。哦，那是某件事。你想知道我是怎么把滑雪板放在车顶上的吗？然后你说，用一根头发。我不知道。你们，我演得太烂了。我简直是在模仿你们。这太尴尬了。
No, no, no. There were so many, like, I love like, do you want to guess? Like, all the like ways, I don't know. I just thought that was brilliant. And then I thought it was so cool that it became a movie. And it got nominated for an Academy Award. That's just like that, like as someone that was a fan of it from the very beginning.
不，不，不。有太多这样的台词了，比如，我喜欢那种，你想猜猜吗？所有的那些方式，我不知道。我只是觉得那太天才了。然后我觉得它能拍成电影真是太酷了。它还获得了奥斯卡提名。作为一个从一开始就是它粉丝的人，这简直……
I was like, amazing. Thank you. That's also a good example of a thing that you do. It actually didn't feel like a risk because it was something that my ex-husband and I just did for like fun, you know? And there was like a small comedy show that asked him to make a video. So like he was like, maybe I'll do that for that. But we were not.
我当时觉得，太棒了。谢谢。这也是你所做事情的一个很好的例子。它实际上并没有让我感到像是一种冒险，因为它只是我和我前夫为了好玩而做的事情，你知道吗？当时有一个小型喜剧演出，他们让他做一个视频。所以他就想，也许我可以为那个做点什么。但我们并不是……
I mean, this was really like we didn't, I didn't even know what like Vimeo was then. And I think it was pre- Instagram. It was. Yeah. So it was like, you know, the idea of like a content creator, like that kind of, that just wasn't, nobody would know what that was. That wasn't a term. And or at least not one that was like so in the zeitgeist or had the function that it has now. And like we just did it for fun. And I think there are so many questions in it because we were like trying to find out who this character is. And then we realized it was just such a funny game to describe his life because he's so small. And the way that he has to live his life is like he's made to be in. inventive he has to in order to survive. And it's just like a pure thing that we did. And it is astounding that it just sort of kept developing. And it also took a long time. Like the movie took us seven years to make. And I think it came out probably a decade, even more than a decade after we made the first short. Well, the weight definitely paid off. It's so great. Well, ladies,
我是说，这真的就像我们当时甚至不知道Vimeo是什么。而且我觉得那是在Instagram之前。是的。所以，你知道，像内容创作者这样的概念，那种……那根本不存在，没人知道那是什么。那不是一个术语。或者至少不是一个在时代精神中如此流行，或者具有现在这种功能的词。我们只是为了好玩才做的。而且我觉得里面有很多问题，因为我们当时在试图弄清楚这个角色是谁。然后我们意识到，描述他的生活是一个非常有趣的游戏，因为他太小了。他必须过的那种生活方式，让他变得很有创造力，为了生存他必须这样做。这只是我们做的一件纯粹的事情。它能不断发展真是令人震惊。而且它也花了很多时间。比如这部电影我们花了七年才拍完。我觉得它上映时，距离我们拍第一部短片可能已经过去十年，甚至超过十年了。嗯，等待绝对是值得的。它太棒了。好吧，女士们，
how about if we take a break? But then we'll come back and we'll chat more. Yeah. Well, I mean, my gosh, there's just so much, Jenny, what you've created is just really astounding. It's really amazing because you're like a multi-hyphenate, right? I always tell Jenna, I want to be a multi-hyphenate on Wikipedia. You're a multi-hyphenate. And you have this book that you just wrote called Lifeform. Do you want to share with us about that? Yeah, sure.
我们要不要休息一下？然后回来再聊更多。是的。好吧，天哪，真的有太多东西了，珍妮，你所创造的一切真的令人震惊。这真的很了不起，因为你是个多重身份者，对吧？我总是告诉珍娜，我想在维基百科上成为一个多重身份者。你就是一个多重身份者。你刚写了一本书叫《生命形式》。你想和我们分享一下吗？好的，没问题。
Lifeform is my second book. It's a book of small pieces that describe the, a five-year period in my life between like when I was single, right, like at the edge of my final single moments right before I met my now has been Ben and all the way through like pregnancy and having a baby and being with a baby and then like ongoing. I think I started to write little pieces while I was pregnant and I don't know if this is a common feeling, but maybe a common fear that like, will this be all I am and do? Like, is this going to be the thing that people ask me about the most, like being pregnant or being a mother. And I think because of that,
《生命形式》是我的第二本书。这是一本由短篇组成的集子，描述了我生命中五年的时光，从我单身的时候开始，就在我遇到现在的丈夫本之前的最后单身时刻，一直到怀孕、生孩子、带孩子，然后是持续的生活。我想我在怀孕时开始写一些小片段，我不知道这是否是一种普遍的感觉，但也许是一种普遍的恐惧，比如，我的人生和成就仅限于此吗？比如，这会是人们问我最多的事情吗，比如怀孕或成为母亲。我觉得正因为如此，
I wanted to see just a greater arc of what my experience was so that I could prove to myself, like, of course, everything is connected. And of course, we have things that stand out or the moments that are the most impactful, but it is all connected and you stay you while you also change. And I think that's, like, in a sort of playful way, what the book represents. But that said, then I was like, I should have done more pregnancy writing, you know, like I still want to reflect on it. And one of the things I'm really excited about right now is my friends, Rebecca's Dinerstein and Julie Bunton, who are these incredible novelists, put together an anthology called Notes to New Mothers, which is just a beautiful book of all different contributors, all of these different people who are experiencing
我想看到我经历的更广阔的弧线，这样我就可以向自己证明，当然，一切都是相互关联的。当然，我们会有一些突出的事情，或者最具影响力的时刻，但这一切都是相连的，你在改变的同时依然保持着自我。我觉得，这在某种程度上以一种俏皮的方式代表了这本书。但话虽如此，后来我就想，我应该写更多关于怀孕的内容，你知道，我仍然想反思它。我现在非常兴奋的一件事是，我的朋友丽贝卡·戴纳斯坦和朱莉·邦顿，她们是了不起的小说家，编纂了一部名为《给新妈妈的笔记》的选集，这是一本非常精美的书，汇集了所有不同的贡献者，所有这些正在经历
motherhood. And I've recently contributed to that. Oh, nice. Yeah, it's out now. But it is something that, like if you have any listeners that are new mothers are about to be mothers or have a mother that they want to get to know. It's like an encyclopedia of experiences and so many different voices and so many different forms. Do you know what that's bringing up in me? I'm getting a little emotional as you talk about this. It's how as a child, I think maybe you don't see your mom as a whole person. You really just see your mom as your mom. But your mom is a whole person. And then for me, as a mom, everything you just said, like, I'm still a whole person with other thoughts and ideas and aspirations. And so I love the idea of this book of essays that sort of put into context that
母亲身份的人。我最近也为它做了贡献。哦，真好。是的，现在已经出版了。但如果你们有听众是新手妈妈，或者即将成为妈妈，或者有一个她们想去了解的母亲，这本书就像是一本经验百科全书，有这么多不同的声音和不同的形式。你知道这在我心里引发了什么吗？当你谈论这个时，我有点激动。作为一个孩子，我觉得也许你并没有把你的妈妈看作一个完整的人。你真的只是把她看作你的妈妈。但你的妈妈是一个完整的人。然后对我来说，作为一个妈妈，你刚才说的一切，比如，我仍然是一个拥有其他想法、观念和抱负的完整的人。所以我喜欢这本散文集，它把那种
idea. Am I making sense? It's like... Completely. Yeah. Absolutely. Mothers are, you can kind of be made flat or like you're just defined in one way. But actually, I mean, at least in my experience, like the experience is deeply personal, even though if you become a parent, you're part of a really, really vast collective, of course. But the personal parts of it are the ones that can make you sometimes feel really isolated. They're sometimes really hard to describe. And they're also the things that are really, really unique that you might seek to present.
想法置于背景中。我表达清楚了吗？就像……完全清楚。是的。绝对。母亲们，你可能会被扁平化，或者你只是以一种方式被定义。但实际上，我是说，至少在我的经验中，这种体验是非常私人的，即使你成为了父母，你也是一个非常、非常庞大的集体的一部分，当然。但其中的个人部分有时会让你感到非常孤立。它们有时真的很难描述。而且它们也是非常、非常独特的，你可能会试图呈现
your own perceptions as a parent and as like a human being. And I think the reason why my own book life form and this new collection that I added pieces to, which is notes to new mother, it's like for me, I just like, I feel like it's so important to have as many different styles and as many different examples as possible, not just so that like more of us can connect, but that like you can get out of your own rut of personal definition. Yeah. Like I always want to be offered different ways to define myself and to not get stuck in an old definition that maybe I put on myself because I'm hard on myself or I'm critical or
你作为父母和作为一个人的感知。我觉得我的书《生命形式》和我添加了片段的这本新集子《给新妈妈的笔记》，对我来说，我觉得拥有尽可能多不同的风格和尽可能多的例子是非常重要的，不仅仅是为了让我们更多人能够产生共鸣，而是为了让你能够走出个人定义的死胡同。是的。我总是希望被提供不同的方式来定义自己，而不是陷入一个旧的定义中，也许那是我强加给自己的，因为我对自我要求很高，或者我很挑剔，或者
I know, whatever. But yeah, I guess I just didn't realize that my view of my own mom would change so much once I became a parent. Yeah, exactly. Jesus Christ, you worked so hard. I called my mom the other day and I said to her, I was like, mom, did you used to go at the beginning of the school year and weed out all the clothes that were stained and didn't fit me anymore and then put my back to school shopping clothes like in my drawer for me because I didn't do it.
我知道，无论如何。但是的，我想我只是没意识到一旦我成为父母，我对自己的妈妈的看法会发生这么大的变化。是的，完全正确。天哪，你工作太辛苦了。我前几天给我妈打电话，我对她说，妈，你以前是不是在学年开始的时候，会把所有弄脏了或者不再合身的衣服清理掉，然后把我的返校购物衣服放进抽屉里，因为我没做过这些事。
And I thought of it because I had just done it for my own kids. And I was like, oh my God, I did not see her do this. had no awareness. But like, I also didn't have a dresser filled with 18 years of clothes. So someone did it. I know my dad didn't do it. But I just wanted to say, I'm really deeply moved by your book. So I'm glad.
我想到这一点是因为我刚刚为我自己的孩子做了这件事。我就想，天哪，我没看到她做这些。我一点意识都没有。但是，我也没有一个装满18年衣服的梳妆台。所以肯定有人做了。我知道我爸爸没做。但我只是想说，你的书深深地打动了我。所以我很高兴。
I am really excited about these books. And I think. Well, we'll definitely share them with our listeners and put little swipe ups on where people can get them. And, you know, a mother's journey never ends. I was just home with my mom, who's 88. and we were doing some laundry. And I said,
我对这些书感到非常兴奋。我想。好吧，我们一定会把它们分享给我们的听众，并放上链接，让大家知道在哪里可以买到。而且，你知道，母亲的旅程永无止境。我刚和88岁的妈妈待在一起，我们当时在洗衣服。我说，
Mom, do you remember that one time? Because my mom's pretty even-kill. And I was like, you remember that one time? You were so frustrated. And you just started throwing everyone's laundry down the hallway. And we both just started laughing. And we don't even remember what it was, but I'm sure none of us were doing our laundry
妈，你还记得那一次吗？因为我妈心态一直很平稳。我就说，你记得那一次吗？你当时太沮丧了。你开始把所有人的衣服扔到走廊里。我们俩都开始大笑。我们甚至不记得是因为什么了，但我敢肯定我们当时谁都没在洗衣服，
and it was all piling up. And so she just had it. But you just see them as just such, just real people, you know. And I think as she's getting older, all those moments of us just like laughing our butts off about some moment, you know, it's just like pile the treasures and keep them close, you know? Oh my God. My mom is somebody who like, I don't think she's not like a big comedy fan. Like she doesn't like need that. It's just like not her deal.
衣服都堆积如山。所以她只是受够了。但你就是把她们看作是真实的人，你知道吗。我觉得随着她越来越老，所有那些我们笑得前仰后合的时刻，你知道，就像堆积宝藏一样，把它们珍藏起来，你知道吗？天哪。我妈妈不是那种……我觉得她不是那种超级喜剧迷。她不需要那种东西。那不是她的菜。
Like I'm not offended by it at all. It's just that's not what she goes towards. She's just, you know, she doesn't even really watch TV at all actually. Or like she'll watch like masterpiece theater. But to get my mom to laugh, it's just rare. It's just so rare. And I've tried directly to like make her laugh and maybe that won't do it. But my sisters and I were talking about like I ended up at a very expensive dollhouse store with my daughter recently.
我不觉得被冒犯了。只是那不是她感兴趣的方向。她，你知道，她甚至其实根本不看电视。或者她会看像《杰作剧场》之类的。但要让我妈笑，真的很难。太难了。我曾直接尝试逗她笑，也许那没用。但我姐妹们和我当时在谈论，比如我最近带着女儿去了一家非常昂贵的玩偶屋商店。
And it like blew my mind and I felt like very upset about it. That it was just so expensive. And I just was like, this is not how much this stuff costs. Like it doesn't. It just it doesn't. I'm looking on Etsy. It doesn't cost this much. And I felt very upset about it.
这让我大吃一惊，我感到非常难过。因为东西太贵了。我就说，这些东西根本不值这个价。根本不值。我在Etsy上查过。根本不需要这么多钱。我对此感到非常难过。
I was telling my sister's like, man, it was just. like crazy. And all I said was, I remember one time when we went with Nana and Papa to the dollhouse store on the Cape and I really wanted this miniature glazed Thanksgiving turkey. And my mom, she did a spit take. Like she's spit out. She was like drinking sangria. I mean, maybe that's why it happened. But like to make her laugh, it was so gratifying. And now generally I just, I'm like, I just want to do nice things for my mom. I didn't. understand how much pressure she was under at all. I definitely didn't understand. Yeah. We were going to ask you like some questions if like you watched the office if there was a
我当时告诉我的姐妹们，天哪，这简直太疯狂了。我只说了一句，我记得有一次我们和奶奶、爷爷去海角的那家玩偶屋商店，我真的很想要那个微型釉面感恩节火鸡。我妈，她当时喷了出来。她当时在喝桑格利亚汽酒。我是说，也许这就是原因。但能让她笑，真的太令人满足了。现在我通常只是，我想为我妈妈做些好事。我以前根本不理解她承受了多大的压力。我绝对不理解。是的。我们本来想问你一些问题，比如如果你看《办公室》，有没有一个
character you identified with. I just have something that I really need you to know. And I've said this to Ed Helms, but you know, like I watched the office when it was on TV. I always loved it. It always was perfect to me. There was one point where I auditioned for it and I didn't get it. What role? It was like, do you remember Dwight? He has an intern. But I don't remember, I don't remember what the name of the part. I just remember being like, oh my God, this is a huge deal. And then not getting it like, but I, yeah, always loved it. Always.
你认同的角色。我真的有一件事需要你知道。我跟艾德·赫尔姆斯说过，但你知道，我在电视上播的时候看了《办公室》。我一直很喜欢它。它对我来说一直很完美。有一次我为它试镜，但我没选上。什么角色？就像，你记得德怀特吗？他有一个实习生。但我记不清了，我不记得那个角色的名字。我只记得当时心想，天哪，这太重要了。然后没选上，就像……但我，是的，一直很喜欢它。一直都是。
I'm always the person like watching it like on a plane. You know, like, I'm just like, I know all the episodes and I'm still watching it. But it had a complete renaissance, a complete new meaning, like complete new power for me and my husband. because when I had my daughter, which was December of 2020. So I was pregnant for the whole start of the pandemic. Like I gave birth in a mask. My family was there. Like I, you know, we were really, really by ourselves.
我总是那个在飞机上看着它的人。你知道，我熟悉所有的剧集，但我还是在看。但它对我丈夫和我来说，有了一次彻底的复兴，一种全新的意义，一种全新的力量。因为我生女儿的时候，是2020年12月。所以我整个疫情初期都在怀孕。比如我戴着口罩生下了孩子。我的家人都在那里。比如我，你知道，我们真的非常、非常孤独。
But every day at like 4.45, we would be like, and the walking part of the day is over. We're done. We're getting in bed. And we would like order takeout. and we would watch the office. And it was, like, many new parents just like, I was so tired. I was so anxious.
但每天下午4点45分左右，我们就会说，一天的散步时间结束了。我们完成了。我们要上床了。我们会点外卖，然后看《办公室》。对于许多新手父母来说，我当时太累了。我太焦虑了。
I was really happy to be doing what I was doing. But, like, it was a lot. And to be able to laugh that hard and, like, we craved the show. Like, we were just looking at the clock being like, it was 4.30. Can we get in bed? And we watched season after season.
我很高兴能做我正在做的事情。但是，这真的很多。能够笑得那么大声，我们渴望这部剧。我们当时盯着时钟，心想，才4点30分。我们可以上床了吗？然后我们一季接一季地看。
We would watch so many episodes tonight. We would watch it until, like, like, one of us just put the baby in her little, snoo thing. And like, and we like, just, it soothed us to sleep. But then if we fell asleep, we would go back and we would watch the episode that we fell asleep. But it was the most comforting, rejuvenating thing.
我们晚上会看很多集。我们会一直看到……直到我们其中一个人把宝宝放进她的小摇篮里。然后我们……它让我们平静入睡。但如果我们睡着了，我们会回去看我们睡着时看的那一集。但那是最令人安慰、最让人恢复活力的东西。
And like it truly gave our family so much joy. And I really like thinking that my daughter, when she was like first in this world, heard me and my husband laugh so much. And it is because of the show. And I know that's so cheesy, but it's really true, really true. And it just means. so much to meet your work and the show. And I love it so much.
它确实给我们的家庭带来了很多快乐。我真的很喜欢想到我的女儿，当她刚来到这个世界时，听到了我和我丈夫笑得那么开心。这都是因为这部剧。我知道这听起来很俗气，但这是真的，真的。能遇见你的作品和这部剧对我来说意义重大。我太爱它了。
And thank you. Thank you. My gosh. That's so wonderful. It's really real. Do you have a favorite episode or character that you particularly gravitated toward? Oh, my God. I mean, I have like a niche secret favorite.
谢谢你。谢谢。天哪。那太美好了。这真的很真实。你有没有特别喜欢的剧集或角色？哦，天哪。我是说，我有一个小众的秘密最爱。
You know Mark Prosh, like him in the warehouse, like when he's just like, that character is just like really. kills me, but I mean, I don't know if people say this. It's really, really, really, really, really hard to pick a fave. But, I mean, I'm like a big Michael fan, even though he often makes me feel really upset and uncomfortable. I also love, like, the episode where he and Toby, like, Toby sort of tricks him into doing, like, kid therapy. Yeah. You know that's like, he's like, I forget that that Michael's stepdad's name, but like Michael's like, my mom, like she spent a lot of time with Jeff. Jeff.
你知道马克·普罗什吗，他在仓库里的时候，当他只是……那个角色真的让我笑死，但我不知道人们是否会这么说。真的、真的、真的、真的、真的很难选出一个最爱。但是，我是说，我是迈克尔的超级粉丝，尽管他经常让我感到非常难过和不舒服。我也喜欢，比如他和托比的那一集，托比诱导他去做儿童心理治疗。是的。你知道那是……他就像，我忘了迈克尔继父的名字了，但迈克尔说，我妈妈，她花了很多时间和杰夫在一起。杰夫。
Yeah, it's Jeff. Oh, who's Jeff? And they're like playing a board game and it's like, Jeff's, I mean, he's okay. Like, it's just so funny. I mean, I don't know. They're all, they're, the CPR episode where Kelly starts dancing. That is such a funny joke. The episode where Andy says beer, beer me a water.
是的，是杰夫。哦，杰夫是谁？他们当时在玩棋盘游戏，就像是，杰夫的，我是说，他还行。这太搞笑了。我是说，我不知道。它们都是，CPR那一集凯莉开始跳舞。那个笑话太搞笑了。安迪说“啤酒，给我一杯水”的那一集。
Well, you do have an office connection through Mike Scher because you, you know, we're on Parks and Rec. Can we talk about Parks and Rec for a hot second before we let you go? I love Mona Lisa. Money, money, money, money. Money, please. Mona Lisa. And just, I mean, I know so many people have talked to you about that. Don't be suspicious.
好吧，你确实通过迈克·舒尔和《办公室》有联系，因为你，你知道，出演了《公园与游憩》。在我们让你走之前，我们能聊聊《公园与游憩》吗？我爱莫娜·丽莎。钱，钱，钱，钱。钱，拜托。莫娜·丽莎。我是说，我知道很多人都和你聊过这个。别怀疑。
Don't be. But I, you know, like, there's some things that come on. You're just like, I'm going to watch that. And I've watched it a gazillion times, but I'm going to watch it again. because it makes me laugh every time. If I am scrolling anywhere and that comes up, I'm like, like it makes me so happy every time. Oh, I'm really glad.
别怀疑。但我，你知道，有些东西播出来，你就会想，我要看那个。我已经看了无数遍了，但我还是要再看一遍。因为它每次都让我发笑。如果我在滚动屏幕时看到那个，我就会想，它每次都让我如此快乐。哦，我真的很高兴。
That part was written for me by my friend Joe Mandy. He was like, I wrote a weird part where you come and do it. Like I never certainly didn't expect that to be a thing at all. And I really enjoyed it. And like I am sure they have like 20 million hours of just garbage like stuff that hit the cutting room floor because Ben and I would not shut up. Like, we just couldn't stop. Also, I didn't even get to like the Angela and Pam of my favorites, especially like Angela's
那部分是我朋友乔·曼迪为我写的。他说，我写了一个奇怪的角色，你来演吧。我当然完全没想到那会成为一个梗。我真的很享受。而且我敢肯定他们有两千万小时的垃圾素材被剪掉了，因为本和我根本停不下来。我们就是停不下来。另外，我甚至还没提到安吉拉和帕姆是我最喜欢的，尤其是安吉拉的
trists like her uptight trists with Dwight. Like those moments are just, especially just because physically you're so tiny and he's so tall. Yeah. You know? Also, there are so many funny Pam moments, but like the episode where you go across the Coles, which is more of a dramatic one, like, this. that makes me cry so much.
私情，比如她和德怀特之间那种紧张的私情。那些时刻真的，尤其是因为从体型上讲你太娇小了，而他太高了。是的。你知道吗？还有，有很多有趣的帕姆时刻，但比如你穿过科尔斯的那一集，那更偏向戏剧性，那真的让我哭得好惨。
And like when you tell Jim that like you used to be best friends and you're not anymore and then it ends in the kiss, that is one of the best episodes of TV. Just to say, I love it so much. God damn. We were very lucky. We were really lucky.
当你告诉吉姆你们曾经是最好的朋友，但现在不是了，然后以一个吻结束，那是电视史上最好的剧集之一。只想说，我太爱它了。该死。我们真的很幸运。我们真的很幸运。
When like Michael has a lot of pairings, you know, that like offset him. You know, like there's Michael and Dwight and there's, you know, like, and Michael and and Holly and like the Michael and Pam of just. Pam, like just really having to take it in and often having to do things that are just so inane. It's so satisfying. Like that just takes an insane amount of nuance and talent. And anyway, I could like truly talk to you guys about this forever. Well, thank you so much for saying all of that.
当迈克尔有很多搭档时，你知道，能衬托他。你知道，有迈克尔和德怀特，有迈克尔和霍莉，还有迈克尔和帕姆，帕姆真的必须承受这一切，而且经常不得不做一些非常愚蠢的事情。这太令人满足了。这需要极大的细微差别和天赋。总之，我真的可以和你们聊这个聊到永远。好吧，非常感谢你说了这么多。
I really related to something you said at the top, which is like, I never saw myself as the bitch. I always am like, hey, guys, what's going on? Hi, hi, y'all. And so when I got cast to that, it was so surprising. My mom says I either play the bitch or the weirdo. She's like very eager for me to play someone like, I guess. I don't know, whatever. But, you know, Jenny, you can come back anytime.
我真的很认同你在开头说的一件事，就是我从来没把自己看作是那个贱人。我总是说，嘿，伙计们，怎么了？嗨，嗨，大家好。所以当我被选为那个角色时，真的很令人惊讶。我妈妈说我不是演贱人就是演怪人。她非常渴望我演一个像……我不知道，随便什么角色。但是，你知道，珍妮，你随时可以回来。
Anything you want to talk about, come back. Because this is so fun. Thank you so much for having me. It's like really, really a highlight of my experience here on Earth that I got to do this. Well, thanks so much, Jenny. Jenny, thank you so much. Oh, my God. I really, really appreciate everything.
任何你想聊的话题，随时回来。因为这太有趣了。非常感谢你们邀请我。这真的是我在地球上经历的一个非常、非常精彩的亮点。好吧，非常感谢，珍妮。珍妮，非常感谢。哦，天哪。我真的、真的非常感激这一切。
Thank you for having me. Yes. Hugs, hugs, hugs. And we'll share all the things. Okay. Okay. Cool. Bye.
谢谢你们邀请我。是的。拥抱，拥抱，拥抱。我们会分享所有的事情。好的。好的。酷。再见。
Bye. Well, that was just so fun. Yeah. Everyone, please be sure to check out Jenny's new movie Forgotten Island in theaters now. It really is a lovely story about friendship. I loved also, by the way, how she said her character might be considered a baddie. but I love how she approached the role with such heart and thoughtfulness. And you know what, you guys?
再见。好吧，那真的太有趣了。是的。大家，请一定要去看看珍妮的新电影《被遗忘的岛屿》，现在正在影院上映。这真的是一个关于友谊的可爱故事。顺便说一句，我也很喜欢她说她的角色可能会被认为是个坏女孩，但我喜欢她以如此真诚和体贴的态度来处理这个角色。你们知道吗，伙计们？
We'll be sure and share about it in our Insta Stories. And I'll also share where you can get Jenny's new book, Life Form, and the book of essays about, Notes to New Mothers. I'm going to remember that book this coming Mother's Day. That is a great idea, lady. Mm-hmm. All right, everyone. Thanks for joining us, and we'll see you next week.
我们一定会分享在我们的Instagram故事里。我也会分享你们在哪里可以买到珍妮的新书《生命形式》，以及那本关于《给新妈妈的笔记》的散文集。这个母亲节我会记得那本书的。那是个好主意，女士。嗯哼。好了，大家。感谢加入我们，我们下周见。
See you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey, and is produced by Jenna Fisher. and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Matt Beagle, and our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis.
到时候见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》是Odyssey的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的高级制作人是马特·比格尔，音频工程师是萨姆·基弗。Odyssey的执行制作人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。
Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Shultz. Our theme song is Rupertree by Creed Bratton. Things are about to heat up. Southern heat, crispy, crunchy, chicken sandwich. No, sushi. Saddle up for something spicy. Introducing the Nashville hot chicken sushi roll by Bento. Find it in a grocery store near you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《鲁珀特树》。事情即将升温。南方热辣，酥脆，嘎吱作响，鸡肉三明治。不，寿司。准备好迎接一些辛辣的东西吧。隆重推出Bento的纳什维尔热辣鸡肉寿司卷。在您附近的杂货店即可找到。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。